-That is a sharp-dressed man
right there.
-Thank you. Ooh!
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at this.
-Hasan, it's good to see --
It's good to see you, buds.
-Oh, thank you.
Are we really buddies?
-Yes, we're buddies.
-No, I'm serious.
-Yes, of course we're buddies.
I know your wife.
I've known you for a long time.
-You know, Jimmy,
I'm at that age now.
I'm 36 and I realized
I don't really have friends.
-What?
-You know this.
You hit a certain age,
and unless, you know,
it's golf, gambling,
or video games,
you have no friends as a --
Steve, do you have any friends?
-Yeah.
-No. Right?
Like, Jimmy, do you
have friends, sincerely?
-No.
-See? That's what I'm saying.
-No, of course --
-No, no, no.
Nancy has friends,
and then you're friends
with their husbands.
Okay? Okay?
And this is why I'm jealous,
because you met Beena backstage.
And Beena has
multiple best friends.
-Yeah.
-Multiple.
-Like, she'll be like, "We have
to go to Sara's wedding.
She's my best friend."
I'm like, "We were just at
Priya's wedding.
I thought she was your
best friend."
And she's like, "You know this.
Best friend
is not an individual.
It is a tier."
-You have a tier of
best friends.
-And I'm like,
"This is just United 1K?
It's 14 girls just vying for
a spot in your tier?"
-Yeah. To be all best friends.
-Ask a grown man.
Be like, "Hey,
who's your best friend?"
They'll be like, "When I was 8?"
Andrew Behrens?
I haven't thought about him
in 28 years."
-That's a good name.
-No, he's real.
Listen,
I was thinking about this.
I was, like -- Yo, I had to fill
out an emergency-contact form,
and there were like --
There's two lines, right?
You know this.
It's -- The first one
was like, "Family member."
The second one, they're like,
"Pick a friend."
The first one,
obviously, was Beena.
And then the second one
was just 911.
They were like, "The ambulance?"
I was like, "No, no.
Don't --" They're like," What if
you're having a heart attack?"
I'm like,
"Don't call my friends.
They'll make fun of me."
I'm serious.
Like, why can't we
support each other, Jimmy?
-Well, you're saying, men of a
certain age, why can't we?
-Yeah, like,
I want my Instagram comments
to be like
Beena's Instagram comments.
Every girl you see
in your life, like,
you go to their
Instagram comments.
Every time I go to Beena's page,
all of her friends, any photo,
"Stunning."
"Gorgeous."
"Hot mama."
"Love your look."
"Killin' it."
"I am screaming."
"Breathtaking."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Breathtaking.
That's right, yeah.
-Tonight, if I go to your
Instagram page and I write,
"breathtaking,"
you will block me.
You'll be like,
"Hasan's on ketamine, I think."
-Breathtaking? Wow.
-Is this is a cry for help?
-That's interesting, yeah.
No, I would never --
I would never block you.
-Do you cry?
Do you go to therapy? Honestly.
-What's going on?
Do I go to therapy?
-Yeah.
-No, I don't go to ther--
I don't.
-Neither do -- See --
-But we can.
-I don't go to therapy,
but I do watch Pixar movies.
Every two years.
Every two years,
I watch a Pixar movie.
-That's all you need.
-Yeah. I get a good cry out.
-Yes!
-Fellas, you've got to cry.
It's like masturbating
for your emotions.
-Thank you.
-You know what I mean?
You just watch "Encanto,"
you're like...
And then you're like,
"I've got to do my taxes."
Just clarity of mind.
-Never heard of that one, yeah.
Never put it that way.
-Okay. Think about this.
Think about this honestly.
-Okay.
-Do you remember the first time
you saw your dad cry?
I was 16. How old were you?
-I mean, gosh,
I don't really remember.
-This is what I'm talking about.
-There's one exact --
-There's one moment, right?
I was 16.
Like, my sister came in.
She's like, "Dad is crying."
It was like seeing a
mountain lion in your driveway.
You're like,
"I know this could happen.
I just didn't think
it would happen to me."
You know what I mean?
Do I walk up to him?
Does he walk up to me?
Do I get big like,
"I'm not here to hurt you"?
Like, what do I say?
-To a mountain lion -- Yeah.
-Right?
Like, we have
these core memories.
There's two core memories
you have as a young man, right?
The first time you see
your dad cry.
-That's correct.
And the first time you see
your dad's [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
You know -- Don't pull a --
You know exactly
what I'm talking about.
Right? You're like 5 years old.
You're in the shower
and you're like, "Whoa!
Papa is packing."
You know, and it's --
'Cause you --
Don't --
Jimmy, don't do this, okay?
It's like IMAX. You're small.
He's -- You know what I mean?
The vantage --
The camera's here, right?
-Oh, no, no, no.
-Think about --
It's like -- Listen, listen.
Don't do that. Don't do that.
I'll use a different word.
It's really -- It's like
watching "Avengers: Endgame"
for us, right?
Like, when we see -- That's what
it is for a little kid.
Like, they're just like,
"Whoa, Thanos is huge.
And purple. And wrinkly."
It's just in IMAX.
-Oh, my God.
Alright, thank you for -- Yeah.
-No, like, it was a treat.
It was a treat to see
your dad's Snuffleupagus.
It was a treat.
I remember the day -- 6-1-91.
Like, I will never forget that.
-You have the date
burned in your memory?
-Yeah, man. It was a treat.
-Wow. Wow.
-And -- You know.
And now I'm making memories
with my son.
So I know he's about to --
So I'll be in the shower
and sometimes, I'll just
get up -- You know what I mean?
I'll just open up a little bit.
Just let him know what it is.
'Cause I want that
to embed in his RAM.
You know what I mean?
Just be like, "Oh, yeah."
I want him to walk into
Bright Horizons
and be like, "Papa is packing."
-Yeah -- Bright Horizons.
-Yeah.
Over on the Upper West Side.
You know what it is.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
I think, for me,
it was the crying
and the other moment
at the exact same time.
I think it happened
at the same time for me.
[ Laughter ]
How is the tour going,
by the way?
You sold out Radio City
five times over?
-It was amazing, man.
-Congratulations.
-Yeah, it's been amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did I get to tell you this,
by the way?
My office is
right by Radio City,
and I saw you outside.
Were you taking photos
on the roof?
-Yeah, that was me on the roof.
I was like, "I got to
let them know what time it is."
-Yeah, I was going to take
a picture of you
through the window of you.
-Oh, you should have done that.
-I know.
But I was so happy for you, bud.
-So, you get to do these great
venues like Radio City,
and then, a few weeks ago,
I was in the South
and I was in Nashville.
And I was performing at
Andrew Jackson Auditorium.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, like,
a little heavy, you know?
The entire time I'm onstage,
and right next to me,
there's just a huge painting
of Andrew Jackson looking at me.
Like, he's just like, "Taaah!
What are all these Indians
doing here?
I thought
we gave them smallpox."
Like, he's so angry.
And the promoter was just like,
"Do you want me to
take it down?"
I'm like, "No, leave it up.
-Ooh.
-I want to anger his ghost."
You know what I mean?
-That's what motivates
you through the set.
-Yeah.
It made me feel a certain way.
And she just goes, "Thank God we
don't have Confederate statues."
I'm like,
"I love Confederate statues."
-You do?
-I was just messing with her.
But I say we leave them up.
Leave them up.
Look, you can't change history.
You can only curate it, Jimmy.
-Curate it.
-Think about it.
I grew up -- I remember.
I learned about the Confederacy.
I learned about Robert E. Lee.
They were called the rebels.
I'm like, "I'm a rebel.
He's just like me.
I don't wear
my retainer at night.
He's just like me."
-You were a rebellious by not
wearing your retainer, yeah.
-And then I looked it up
this past week.
Do you know how long
the Confederacy lasted?
-I don't.
-Anyone here?
Four years, three months.
Yo, I was an undergrad
longer than the Confederacy.
Dude, my wife's IUD lasted
"Jersey Shore"
lasted six seasons.
Alright, some of you guys
aren't laughing.
I see that there's virgins
here tonight.
So, an IUD...
No, no. You don't know this.
An IUD is
a tiny piece of copper.
It goes inside of
a woman's uterus.
It's shaped like the Tesla logo.
-Okay, alright, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
-Right?
[ Rimshot ]
Alright? Okay? Okay?
And that lasted longer than
the Confederacy.
So, here's what I say.
I say we keep up the
Robert E. Lee statue,
then we have Snooki next to it,
and then we have my wife's IUD,
just for historical context.
-Good luck with
the rest of the tour.
Hasan Minhaj, everybody.
For tickets,
go to hasanminhaj.com.
"The King's Jester"
is the name of the tour.
Hasan and I are playing
a fun game after the break.
Stick around.